so i have to tell you i i absolutely
love this story i i actually take
pleasure in bringing you this hilarious
story as you know republicans are
currently the most anti-vaccine group in
the united states there's no single
factor
that predicts being against covet
vaccination as much as being a
republican republicans love to say well
look at anti-vax in the black community
sure there's a history of that we've
talked about where it comes from but it
is republicans that are the most
anti-vaccine group in the united states
and for trump personally this is a
problem
he believes he created the vaccines now
he didn't
but trump believes vaccines work which
they do but so many of his followers
don't believe that
prominent black conservative voice
candace owens scored an interview with
donald trump
in which apparently she thought that she
and trump were going to commiserate and
sort of do their anti-vac stuff together
for the audience
but donald trump actually shuts it down
and there are like five or six different
interesting things here let's look at
the clip which has gone completely viral
and then we'll talk about it we see the
corruption right it doesn't seem like
anybody ever pays for the corruption and
right now we're seeing corruption live
even in terms of big pharma which is a
huge topic on the minds of mothers
especially you're seeing what's
happening at these school board meetings
where do you stand on these vaccine
mayonnaise and obviously i know that you
are you are pro-vaccine obviously you
did everything you could to get this
vaccine out i know it was one of the
greatest achievements we did it in less
than nine months to be able to do that
but where but now it's taken a twist
right it's gotten now we went from this
is a good thing and people should have
this option to
military men you're going to have to
resign because you're not getting this
vaccine where do you stand on that well
i stand on forget about the mandates
that people have to have their freedom
but at the same time
the vaccine is one of the greatest
achievements of mankind we would have
had a 1917
remember the spanish flu killed perhaps
100 million people actually it ended the
first world war because the soldiers
were so a lot of people don't know that
the soldiers got so sick it was a
terrible thing there were no vaccines
they would know anything i came up with
a vaccine with three vaccines all are
very very good came up with three of
them in less than nine months it was
supposed to take five to twelve years
and people have died under cobit this
year by the way under joe biden then
under you and more people took the
vaccine this year so people are
questioning how the vaccine work but
some people aren't taking the ones the
ones that get very sick and go to the
hospital are the ones that don't take
the vaccine but it's still their choice
and if you take the vaccine you're
protected look the results of the
vaccine are very good and if you do get
it it's a very minor form
people aren't dying when they take the
vaccine about the masking of children
now even in this clip trump lies trump
tells a bunch of lies in this clip but
specifically on the vaccines he brutally
schools candace owens but he's still
lying trump lies again about the spanish
flu he calls it the 1917 flu it was from
1918 he says it ended world war one it
didn't so he's still telling his lies in
this clip that we've heard from him so
many times but he's way more honest than
candace owens is about the vaccines
themselves but the most important lie is
that trump didn't come up with any
vaccines trump had nothing to do with
laying the groundwork for mrna
technology which has been researched for
decades and predates donald trump's
presidency predates trump's awareness of
it even
trump didn't sequence the virus he
didn't fund the sequencing of the virus
the u.s government under trump
pre-purchased some doses which many
countries do
and in fact the trump administration
didn't even pre-purchase enough doses
but lies aside trump is right
the people dying are overwhelmingly the
unvaccinated do some vaccinated people
die yes of course
uh but he is completely correct about
that and it's amazing to watch candice
owens squirm and move the goal post and
say well yeah but the mandates that's
bad right and trump says yeah and the
masks on kids are bad right in terms of
yeah
those are bad but the vaccines work now
what happened after the fact is
incredible
and it shows you how corroded this
right-wing movement is
candace owens ended up being ridiculed
and attacked by almost everyone the left
ridiculed candace owens for being so
dumb about vaccines that trump had to
correct her
many on the right are mad at candace
owens for doing an interview with trump
which ended up being pro-vaccine at the
end of the day and a ton of
right-wingers are saying why didn't she
correct trump why didn't she give him
the evidence that she supposedly has so
candace owens has responded to this by
saying nah you know trump's just too old
to understand how bad vaccines are and
this is wild for two reasons which i'll
tell you in a moment but let's look at
what candice owens came up with to
explain what happened like sort of
believing that trump has like sold out
or that trump is a part of the big
pharma syndicate and my honest
assessment is that he just genuinely
believes
that the vaccines are good and he
believes that because he comes from a
generation like people you oftentimes
forget like how old trump is he comes
from a generation i've seen other people
that are older have the exact same
perspective like they came from a time
before tv before internet before being
able to conduct their independent
research you know and everything that
they read
in a newspaper if that was pitched to
them that they believed that that was a
reality and one of those things was you
know this push for vaccines and
believing that people were gonna die
without vaccines and so i believe that
his support of the vaccine is genuine
and it's not based in any corruption
at all i think he actually believes
those things and people that are saying
how is he ignoring all the people that
are being injured and you know people
are sending rumble videos and all of
these you know websites obscure websites
i believe also that he only reads the
mainstream media news believe it or not
i do not believe that trump reads um or
partakes in any other news sources um
you know i don't believe that trump is
on the internet or you know that he
necessarily uses
like you know the the web to try to find
you know obscure websites i think that
he just relies on you know
typical mainstream sources so i don't
think that there's anything evil going
on there i just wanted to say that
because so many
donors supporters of his have are kind
of like questioning where all this is
coming from and i think he just
genuinely believes that um and he needs
to sit down and you know have a full
conversation with someone um i'm in i
was interviewing him in that
circumstance but he needs to have a
larger conversation
to really understand what's going on and
why
so many people are
just horrified so there it is trump's
just too old to understand why vaccines
are so bad except a ton of the very
anti-vaxxers that follow trump are also
trump's age or close to it
and the anti-vac stuff is spreading on
facebook which skews dramatically older
how is trump ignoring all the rumble
videos candace owen asks it is beyond
parody but the real issue is donors she
mentions donors
her money
and everyone's money
is now at risk because of this and it's
also funny that she says trump needs to
go talk to someone about this i mean i
was interviewing him at the time but i
mean a larger conversation what she
means is she needs some other
anti-vaxxer
better versed on the talking points to
have a sit down with trump and try to
convince him actually the vaccines are
no good
at the end of the day what happened is
that her donors didn't like hearing the
truth from trump it destroyed her
narrative and that's it
and absolutely amazing conflicting lies
i tweeted about the fallout uh over the
weekend so it seems now trumpists love
trump because he developed the vaccines
which he didn't
but hate him because he said the vaccine
works which it does
this completely
triggered one time alex jones at one
time donald trump supporter alex jones
by the way the conspiracy theorist and i
want to talk about that next
one of our sponsors is athletic greens
which makes comprehensive daily
nutrition really simple
people are busy we're not always getting
effective balanced nutrition from the
food we eat
we sometimes are combining all sorts of
different vitamins supplements different
things that may be relevant to us ag-1
by athletic greens is a delicious drink
that just simplifies the entire thing
it's one product you get all of the
things you need 75 vitamins minerals and
whole food sourced ingredients it's a
multivitamin it's a multi-mineral it's a
probiotic green food blend in one daily
serving really easy high quality bio
available ingredients can fill those
nutritional gaps in your diet and they
can help with gut health and digestion
and support you in other ways and they
can replace multiple products and pills
that you might be taking it's just one
drink really simple i've been enjoying
the ag-1 drink by athletic greens tastes
good
helps me get everything i'm trying to
get athletic greens is giving my
audience a free one-year supply of
vitamin d and five free travel packs
with your first purchase when you go to
athleticgreens.compacman
the link is in the podcast notes